hey guys guess what you get to pick out
my clothes this week you're gonna pick
out my outfits yeah
wait are you gonna help pick out my
outfits hello darling humans I'm Hannah
and I haven't quite figured out what I'm
gonna do to intro this but in the last
couple of videos we've done we post a
number that you guys can text me to say
any ideas that you have for future
episodes and it was very clear what you
guys wanted and so we're gonna give it
to you today I let my kids trust me for
a whole week it was very fun it was very
weird
and I learned a lot so first as always I
needed to lay some ground rules most
importantly so I didn't get arrested in
this experiment for like public
indecency or something first rule was I
needed to be fully clothed there was
going to be no underwear in place of
pants or bathing suit tops in place of
shirts or underwear on my head as a hat
because I have two boys they think it's
very funny so second I tried to give
them equal opportunity to each choose an
outfit for those of you who understand
what life is like with two boys there's
a lot of conflict around sharing so I
just straight-up delegated days to each
kids so that it wasn't an hour of them
like arguing over who got to pick what
and third I had to do this for seven
days and I had to follow through with
whatever outfit they chose within reason
and I immediately regretted that day one
of these boys picking out my clothes so
day one I decided Jackson would pick my
outfit because he's pretty stylish he
likes to dress himself he kind of knows
how to coordinate outfits and that day I
happen to have a friend in town who was
visiting and so I was taking her to the
Getty Villa in Malibu and we were gonna
be around a lot of people because it's a
big tourist attraction so right off the
bat he picked the top and he chooses
this off-the-shoulder kind of billowy
flowy pink and black tie-dyed top that I
actually just bought recently and I love
that shirt okay what he chose for the
bottoms were these children
Old Navy size large shorts that I had
gotten out of children's thrift store
and they were baby blue with white polka
dot oh my god yeah big dress I looked
like a spotted deranged Oompa Loompa in
this outfit and keep staring at me and I
think they're staring at my hair and
then I realized let me tell you nobody
was looking at the art that day they
were looking at my outfit that was a
pretty ridiculous way to start out the
experiment it was kind of like my worst
fear is all coming true on day one so
day two I gave Jackson a chance to
redeem himself we needed a do-over so he
chose a really cute romper that I love
and actually gave me a hoodie to wear to
which I was excited about because it was
chilly out that day so I left the house
feeling very happy in my cute romper
until I remembered one thing I totally
forgot that today I have a doctor's
appointment and TMI but it's a female
doctor's appointment where you have to
undress from the waist down you girls
out there know the struggle of trying to
like pee and a romper you have to just
take everything off and like get
completely naked in the stall I was
about to have to do that in the doctor's
office
so I have a t-shirt that I'm gonna bring
into the office to change when they ask
me to take my clothes off from the waist
down and as if it's not awkward enough
to go to like the lady doctor it would
have been so much more awkward if she
came back in the room and I was like hey
it's me naked so day two you know it was
a cute outfit it's just when you're
having someone else pick out your
clothes they're not thinking of what
your day is going to be especially when
they're five years old so day three
Jackson's choice once again I think he
was in kind of a weird mood because he
chose this random t-shirt for me to wear
and it's like a yellow t-shirt with a
girl on a motorcycle and it says
motorcycles put something exciting
between your legs he doesn't know how to
read and then he chose these kind of
silly floral shorts to pair with it
all right we don't have much of a dress
code at work and it's pretty casual
because it's a creative environment and
we're allowed to kind of like wear what
makes this comfortable but this was just
like I thought weird walking in the door
but luckily that day Jackson was coming
to work with me and he decided for
himself he wanted to wear some Halloween
costume werewolf hands to work with me I
got a weird kid what can I say
so at least we looked for you to kill us
together
rolling up on day four I don't know what
to expect at this point it was Wyatt's
choice today so first he tried to choose
the romper that I'd already worn but I
vetoed that because I figured this
experiment is best with seven separate
outfits so instead he chose a jumpsuit
that I bought on sale online without
trying on and then it arrived and it fit
and then the second I washed it it
shrank and it was like way too tight way
too tight since it was really tight if I
wore any underwear under it it would
have shown so I had no choice but to go
commando and with that being said I had
to tie a sweater around my waist to
avoid any camel toe mishaps because I
was going to work in this leave it to
Wyatt to almost make me expose all of my
parts to everybody at work so day five
was finally the first collaborative
effort between both kids and they
actually ended up dressing me
head-to-toe because they got so involved
in this they decided they had to pick my
shoes so Jackson and Wyatt collectively
chose this really beautiful blue dress
that I really enjoy wearing and then
Jackson just had to kind of pull out
some sort of wild card he's doing
not dressed in my PJs shorts according
to Jackson you can't wear a dress
without bottoms don't know where he's
getting these fashion rolls but he ended
up choosing the most bulky pair of
pajama shorts I own for me to wear under
it it was a very bulky day very bulky
day how do you like my outfit Jackson
you still like it good let's see what
daddy thinks what do you think of my
outfit I love it
so day six almost at the end and day six
was straight up why it's time to shine
and I think he had spent the past five
days really thinking about what he
wanted because the second I told him he
could choose my outfit he just bolted to
this random knit poncho that I've had
hanging in my closet for years this this
poncho yes okay oh yeah jump on it make
sure it make sure it's nice and worn in
right end up deciding on some denim
cutoffs
to pair with it I looked like I was
ready for an evening Coachella show my
kids are gonna look back on this and
watch it and be like holy crap mom
you're embarrassing kendrick lamar on
the main stage I just realized that this
whole I experiment with having my kids
trust me has forced me to wake up a lot
earlier because usually I just like
throw on whatever the first thing I grab
is out of my closet but they actually
like to take their time choosing my
outfits so I'm I'm exhausted I'm really
tired so day seven the grand finale I
decided that I wanted you guys to
experience this with me live so today is
actually my day seven outfit it is
brought to you 100% by Jackson he
dressed me head-to-toe this time and I
think he kind of wanted to go out with a
bang because he was very adamant about
picking something a little more formal
for me and kept saying mom you gotta
look nice you gotta look nice and today
I got a lot of compliments from my
co-workers oh dear
what you look super cute I don't know if
I just generally dress crappy or if this
past week has been so ridiculous
you Jackson dressed me oh my god can he
dress me he's diamond so after a week of
like really all over the place outfits
real hit and mrs. Jackson comes through
on day 7 and I feel really good about
myself I don't know how to model what do
you do with your hands so what did I
learn this week well I actually learned
a whole lot more than I thought I would
first and foremost I need to clean out
my damn closet the fact that these items
like the poncho the jumpsuit and the
polka dot shorts were in my closet and
in my drawers that's on me that's my
fault the second thing I learned is that
I could afford to spend some more time
choosing my outfit I think a lot of you
moms out there can also relate the
morning is mostly spent making sure that
my children are fully clothed and
dressed and then I'm kind of an
afterthought but I realized I go to work
I see people I need to look presentable
so it's important for me to spend some
time on myself in my outfit and make
sure that I feel confident and look nice
and the final thing I learned is that I
don't give a crap what anyone else
thinks and that is something that I've
noticed hello and the third thing that I
learned is that I don't give a crap what
anyone else thinks of me what and this
is something that I've realized since
having kids you're so concerned about
all this other stuff what other people
think of you and how other people are
seeing you is kind of your last priority
as a parent but being at the Getty
wearing that ridiculous outfit having
everybody staring at me was fine I mean
I had to keep reminding myself that I
was wearing something weird and that's
why everyone was looking because I
didn't even notice and I did not care so
if you are a parent and you're not
feeling the most confident have your kid
dress you for a day go out in public and
just be like screw you everybody this is
what
I'm happy so that's what I got for today
I'm Hanna and I absolutely loved trying
this I loved this idea I love hearing
what you guys want to see so please send
me more ideas leave them in the comments
or text me this is a real number I read
every text
I don't reply to all of them because I
get a lot but I do read every text that
you guys send it and I love hearing what
you guys want to see now if you'll
excuse me I'm gonna go change into
sweatpants and a t-shirt because that's
me until next time can you smile
we item the best smile
[Music]